This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. This month is all about gratitude. And you know, sometimes there's one person that we just don't thank enough, and that's ourselves. Because sometimes it's hard to remind ourselves that we are trying our best to make sense of everything in this crazy world, and it just, it's not easy. It's not, it's a lot to hold.
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。这个月的主题是感恩。你知道吗，有时候我们最没有好好感谢的人，其实是我们自己。因为有时候我们很难提醒自己，在这个疯狂的世界里，我们正在尽最大努力去理解一切，这真的不容易。真的，要承受的东西太多了。
Listen, I think accessing gratitude is so good for your mental health. Yeah. And therapy is a great place to do that. And if you are thinking of starting therapy, you can give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. I am grateful for therapy. Yes! Let the gratitude flow with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month.
听着，我认为学会感恩对你的心理健康非常有益。是的。而心理咨询是一个很好的途径。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，可以试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行。旨在为你提供方便、灵活且适合你日程安排的服务。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可匹配到一位持证心理咨询师，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。我很感激有心理咨询。是的！让感恩通过BetterHelp流动起来吧。今天就访问BetterHelp.com/officeladies，首月可享九折优惠。
That's BetterHelp. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. The epic return of Yellowstone is now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus. You destroy me, you destroy yourself. Unlike you, I keep my promises. The wait is over. Yellowstone, new episodes now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus. Plus. Hi, everyone. Are you ready for second drink of diversity day? This is still one of my all time favorite episodes of the office. I used the second drink as an excuse to watch this episode again and I found two catches.
那是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠office ladies。《黄石》史诗级回归，现正于Paramount Plus独家热播。你毁了我，就是毁了你自己。和你不同，我信守承诺。等待结束了。《黄石》，新剧集现正于Paramount Plus独家热播。Plus。大家好。你们准备好迎接“多元化日”的第二杯饮品了吗？这仍然是我个人最喜欢的《办公室》剧集之一。我把这第二杯饮品当作借口，又看了一遍这一集，我发现了两个小细节。
Are you ready for them? Mm hmm. I think I have an idea of the first one. Go. Number one, there is still a cat calendar at reception. Caught it, saw it. I don't know why I'm obsessed with this, but I'm gonna track it. I need to know when that cat calendar comes down.
准备好听了吗？嗯哼。我想我猜到了第一个。说吧。第一，前台那里还是有一个猫咪日历。抓到了，看到了。我不知道为什么我对这个这么执着，但我会一直追踪它。我需要知道那个猫咪日历什么时候会被撤掉。
I'm wondering if it's the whole first season, but anyway, we're gonna track it. We'll let you know. Also, at 12 minutes and 28 seconds, when we're all loading into the conference room to hear Michael's presentation on diversity. I noticed John and Brian are smirking at one another when they enter and sit down.
我在想是不是整个第一季都有，但不管怎样，我们会追踪它的。我们会告诉你们。另外，在12分28秒，当我们都走进会议室去听迈克尔关于多元化的演讲时。我注意到约翰和布莱恩在进入并坐下时，正对着彼此坏笑。
It is a total break of character. I don't know what they were talking about before we started rolling, but you can watch two friends. Having a dude bro moment. 100%. Well, I rewatched it as well, and I wanna talk about something that happens
这完全是出戏了。我不知道我们在开拍前在聊什么，但你可以看到两个朋友。正在进行那种哥们儿间的互动。百分之百。好吧，我也重看了，我想聊聊发生在
at 13 minutes and seven seconds. Okay. All right, everyone is entering the conference room scene and they are gonna watch Michael's video that he has made. Yes, it's very short. It's very short, but I guess when they were filming it, they let Steve and Rain play around at the top of it. It is so funny.
13分07秒的事情。好的。好吧，每个人都进入了会议室场景，他们要看迈克尔制作的视频。是的，非常短。非常短，但我猜他们在拍摄时，让史蒂夫和雷恩在开头即兴发挥了一下。太搞笑了。
I was cracking up, it's in deleted scenes, and you really hear the build of Michael getting so pissed off with Dwight. Dwight is his camera operator. And what I love is that you hear Steve and Rain as Dwight and Michael just discovering who these characters are to one another. It's so fun, let's hear it.
我当时笑得不行，这在删减片段里，你真的能听到迈克尔对德怀特变得越来越恼火的过程。德怀特是他的摄像师。我喜欢的是，你能听到史蒂夫和雷恩作为德怀特和迈克尔，正在探索彼此之间的角色关系。太有趣了，我们来听听。
Don't do that. Just say action when we're ready. Dunder Mifflin, Michael Scott, Diversity Tomorrow, take four. And action. Try, try, no. Do it again. Diversity Tomorrow, take five.
别那样做。我们准备好时你只管说“开始”。邓德·米福林，迈克尔·斯科特，多元化明天，第四条。开始。尝试，尝试，不。再来一次。多元化明天，第五条。
Action. Hi, I'm Michael Scott. I'm in charge of Dunder Mifflin Paper Products here in Scranton, Pennsylvania. But I'm also the founder of Diversity Tomorrow because today is almost over. Abraham Lincoln once said that if you're a racist, I will attack you with the North.
开始。嗨，我是迈克尔·斯科特。我负责宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的邓德·米福林纸业公司。但我也是“多元化明天”的创始人，因为今天快结束了。亚伯拉罕·林肯曾经说过，如果你是个种族主义者，我会用北方来攻击你。
And those are the principles. Damn it. OK, sorry. Don't laugh. Please don't laugh this time, do I? It's bugging me. Let me give myself a countdown. Ready?
这就是原则。该死。好吧，抱歉。别笑。请这次别笑，德怀特？这让我很烦。让我给自己倒数。准备好了吗？
Three, two, one. Take six. Just let me do it. God. Three, two, one. Hi, I'm Michael Scott. I'm in charge of Dunder Mifflin Paper Products here in Scranton.
三，二，一。第六条。让我自己来吧。天哪。三，二，一。嗨，我是迈克尔·斯科特。我负责斯克兰顿的邓德·米福林纸业公司。
Keep the camera steady, please. People are going to get seasick watching this. Ready? Three, two, one. Action. Don't. Please don't say anything. Oh, god.
请保持摄像机稳定。人们看这个会晕船的。准备好了吗？三，二，一。开始。别。请什么都别说。哦，天哪。
And action. Lights, camera, action whenever you're ready. Could I count myself down, please, Dwight? Three, two, one. Hi, I'm Michael Scott. I'm in charge of Dunder Mifflin Paper Products here in Scranton, Pennsylvania. Oh my gosh, I could listen to those guys do that all day.
开始。灯光，摄像，准备好随时开始。我能自己倒数吗，德怀特？三，二，一。嗨，我是迈克尔·斯科特。我负责宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的邓德·米福林纸业公司。天哪，我可以听他们那样做一整天。
Me too, he's so funny. So funny. He's like, don't say anything. And he's like, take six. He's like, don't say anything. I know. Well, I want to share something. I want to share a song that was written by a fan that was inspired by the moment when
我也是，他太搞笑了。太搞笑了。他就像是，别说什么。然后他说，第六条。他就像是，别说什么。我知道。好吧，我想分享一些东西。我想分享一首由粉丝创作的歌，灵感来自于这一集结尾
Pam falls asleep on Jim's shoulder at the end of this episode. Get out. The song was written by Annika Wells. It is so lovely. I want to hear it. I can't wait for you to hear it. I'll leave you sleeping on my shoulder when the meeting's over I'll save your life from total boredom and expired yogurt
帕姆在吉姆肩膀上睡着的那一刻。别开玩笑了。这首歌是由安妮卡·威尔斯创作的。太可爱了。我想听听。我迫不及待想让你听听。会议结束后，我会让你在我的肩膀上睡觉，我会把你从无聊和过期的酸奶中拯救出来。
So take your time, three years, that's fine I'll wait until the season three finale, it's a date Cause you're my gem and I'm your Pam I fell in love with my best friend No one's ever loved me like you do Cause no one's gem and Pam like me and you Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, Add the chilies. I'll kiss you not so sober. So meet me on the rooftop Don't be late. I'll bring the grilled cheese if you keep me on your plate Cuz you're my gem. I'm your Pam. I fell in love with my best friend No one's ever loved you like I do
所以慢慢来，三年，没关系，我会等到第三季大结局，不见不散。因为你是我的吉姆，我是你的帕姆，我爱上了我最好的朋友。没有人像你这样爱过我，因为没有人像我和你一样是吉姆和帕姆。哦，哦，哦……加点辣椒。我会吻你，虽然没那么清醒。所以我们在屋顶见面，别迟到。如果你让我留在你的盘子里，我会带上烤奶酪。因为你是我的吉姆，我是你的帕姆。我爱上了我最好的朋友，没有人像我这样爱过你。
We'll go down in history The longest, cutest love story We could make a season 10, it's true Cause no one's Jim and Pam like me and you Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh Isn't that incredible? It's so good. It's so good. And I want to point out that in the lyrics, she said they kissed it chilly. I knew you were going to say that, Angela. I knew it the second I heard it.
我们将载入史册，最长、最可爱的爱情故事。我们可以拍第十季，真的。因为没有人像我和你一样是吉姆和帕姆。哦，哦，哦……这不可思议吗？太棒了。太棒了。我想指出歌词里她说他们吻了辣椒。我就知道你会这么说，安吉拉。我听到那一秒我就知道了。
That's right, because that is when they first kissed. I am sorry not to get back into that debate. I feel seen. But also that song is so lovely. We have to share it. We do. And you can download it on Spotify everybody. So we'll tell you where to find it. We'll link to it. All right. Join us this Wednesday as we break down the accountants webisodes. But now let's get to our second drink of diversity day. Enjoy. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
没错，因为那就是他们第一次接吻的时候。抱歉，不想再回到那个争论中去了。我感觉被看穿了。但这首歌真的太可爱了。我们必须分享它。我们会的。大家可以在Spotify上下载。我们会告诉你们在哪里找到它。我们会放上链接。好的。周三加入我们，我们将解析《会计师》网络剧集。但现在，让我们进入“多元化日”的第二杯饮品。享受吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everyone, this is Jenna Fisher. And this is Angela Kinsey. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好，我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。
And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office.
我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。
And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. And we're going to be talking about the ultimate office. were there can tell you. We're the Office Ladies. Hello everyone, this is Jenna Fischer. And this is Angela Kinsey. And today you're listening to Office Ladies and we will be breaking down Diversity Day. It's a good one. Season one, episode two. This was written by BJ Novak and directed by Ken Quapis. It was. This was the moment for me, I was like, we have a hit.
我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。我们将讨论终极《办公室》。只有身临其境的人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好，我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。今天你们收听的是《办公室》女士，我们将解析《多元化日》。这一集很棒。第一季，第二集。这是由BJ·诺瓦克编写，肯·夸皮斯执导的。确实。对我来说，那一刻我觉得，我们成功了。
This is great stuff. Yeah, this was, oh my gosh, it's happening to me again. What's happening? I have so many things in my head to talk about this episode. It's like the little cards in my head are filtering and I don't know which one to pick first. Oh, like a Rolodex? Yes.
这太棒了。是的，这，天哪，它又在我身上发生了。发生什么了？我脑子里有太多关于这一集的东西要说了。就像我脑子里的那些小卡片在过滤，我不知道该先选哪一张。哦，像名片盒一样？是的。
Like that? Yes, yes. That's what's happening. And then I freeze up. Then you freeze up. And you kind of look like deer in headlights when I look at you. Yeah, I just stopped talking. I sort of shut down like a computer screen.
像那样？是的，是的。就是这样。然后我就僵住了。然后你就僵住了。当我看着你时，你看起来就像被车灯照住的鹿。是的，我只是停止说话。我像电脑屏幕一样关机了。
You know what? The same thing happens to me at a buffet. I love a buffet. I can't decide. Too many choices. Too many choices. I'm like, do I want pancakes or do I want like the crab legs or their sushi? What buffet has crab legs and pancakes?
你知道吗？我在自助餐厅也会发生同样的事情。我喜欢自助餐。我无法决定。选择太多了。选择太多了。我心想，我是想要煎饼，还是想要蟹腿或者寿司？哪家自助餐有蟹腿和煎饼？
Like go to a buffet in Vegas. I love a Vegas buffet. Touche. Touche. OK, let's do it. All right, I'm going to start with a synopsis. You love it. That seems good.
去拉斯维加斯的自助餐吧。我喜欢拉斯维加斯的自助餐。说得好。说得好。好吧，我们开始吧。好的，我先来个剧情简介。你喜欢这个。听起来不错。
All right, in the episode diversity day, the staff of Dunder Mifflin must complete a diversity training seminar due to some complaints to corporate. But manager Michael Scott feels the training was insufficient and subjects the staff to his own training. That's it in a nutshell. Yes. That's it, folks.
好的，在《多元化日》这一集中，邓德·米福林的员工必须完成一场多元化培训研讨会，因为公司收到了一些投诉。但经理迈克尔·斯科特觉得培训不够充分，于是让员工接受他自己的培训。简而言之就是这样。是的。就是这样，伙计们。
And my gosh. I mean, just when I rewatched it, it was so awkward. It's so awkward. This is like Michael Scott at his, he has his most cringy this first season, I feel like. Yeah, they really leaned in. They leaned in. Okay, Jenna, go.
天哪。我的意思是，当我重看它时，它太尴尬了。太尴尬了。我觉得这是迈克尔·斯科特在第一季中最令人尴尬的时刻。是的，他们真的深入挖掘了。他们深入挖掘了。好的，珍娜，开始吧。
All right. Shall I start with some fast facts? I am waiting. I can't wait to see what you got. I see. All right, so my first fast fact is that this was the first totally original script of the American version of The Office because we talked about in the pilot that this was based
好的。我先从一些速记事实开始？我等着呢。我迫不及待想看你准备了什么。我看到了。好的，我的第一个速记事实是，这是美版《办公室》第一个完全原创的剧本，因为我们在试播集中谈到过，它是基于
on a British television show of the same name and the pilot episode was an adaptation of their script. This was not. After the pilot episode of our show, we started writing original storylines for our version of the show. That's right. Unique to the American, The Office. That's right.
一部同名的英国电视节目，试播集是他们剧本的改编版。这一集不是。在我们的试播集之后，我们开始为我们的版本编写原创故事线。没错。美版《办公室》独有的。没错。
And the writers referred to this episode as the pilot after the pilot. Ooh, that's good little insight, guys. That's a little insight. The pilot after the pilot. Because they felt like this was establishing what is the American version going to be like? Oh, wow. Diversity. Boy.
编剧们把这一集称为“试播集之后的试播集”。哦，这真是个很好的见解，伙计们。这是一个小见解。试播集之后的试播集。因为他们觉得这一集确立了美版《办公室》会是什么样子？哦，哇。多元化。天哪。
That's the pilot. That's it. Oh my God. I think when we think about this episode, Angela, we both talked about this. It is absolutely brilliant. It's brilliant. People love it. And in rewatching it after all these years, I couldn't believe how remarkably it held up.
这就是试播集。就是这样。天哪。我想当我们想到这一集时，安吉拉，我们都谈过这个。它绝对是天才之作。太棒了。人们喜欢它。在多年后重看它时，我简直不敢相信它竟然如此经得起时间的考验。
Yeah. I mean, it's just a stunning piece of comedy in my opinion. And it was written by BJ Novak, who plays Ryan the temp on the show. Also you guys is like really smart. He is one of the smartest people I know. One time him and Mindy were having a conversation, like, and I walked up and I was just like, hey.
是的。我的意思是，在我看来，这是一部令人惊叹的喜剧作品。它是由在剧中饰演临时工瑞安的BJ·诺瓦克编写的。你们也知道，他真的很聪明。他是我认识的最聪明的人之一。有一次他和敏迪在聊天，我走过去，只是说，嘿。
And they were talking about sort of like some kind of advanced economics kind of conversation. And I was just like, okay, bye. I think it's why Mindy and BJ became best friends was because they are just two of the smartest people in the world. They're the only people they can talk to. Well, I just knew in that moment,
他们在谈论某种高级经济学话题。我当时就想，好吧，再见。我想这就是为什么敏迪和BJ成为最好的朋友，因为他们是世界上最聪明的人。他们是彼此唯一能交流的人。好吧，那一刻我
I had nothing to add to their conversation, and I just did the slow fade, because I was like, wow, these are two really smart people. Well, let me lay something on you about BJ Novak in this episode. He was 25 years old when he wrote it. Shut the front door! What were you doing when you were 25 years old?
对他们的谈话毫无补充，我就慢慢退出了，因为我想，哇，这两个人太聪明了。好吧，让我告诉你关于BJ·诺瓦克在这一集里的一些事。他写这一集时才25岁。关上那扇门！你25岁时在做什么？
Oh, Jenna. I'll tell you what I wasn't doing. I wasn't writing a brilliant piece of television comedy. I was an operator at 1-800-DENTIST. Yeah. I think I was working in a medical office as a receptionist, transcribing medical documents, which is interesting work, by the way.
哦，珍娜。我告诉你我没在做什么。我没在写一部精彩的电视喜剧。我当时是1-800-DENTIST的接线员。是的。我想我当时在一家医疗办公室做前台，转录医疗文件，顺便说一句，这工作很有趣。
It sounds a little gross. Well, it was a psychological office. So what these psychologists did was, if you were applying for an executive position at an important company, you had to go through a psychological evaluation and then these psychologists would determine whether or not they could recommend you for the job or not. And you wrote it all down?
听起来有点恶心。好吧，那是一家心理诊所。所以这些心理学家做的是，如果你申请一家重要公司的高管职位，你必须通过心理评估，然后这些心理学家会决定他们是否能推荐你担任该职位。你把这一切都写下来了？
I transcribed all of the sessions, all of the therapy sessions with the executives. Jenna, this sounds like a HBO series. Oh my gosh. You should pitch that. Okay, sorry, we're getting off topic. Well, I want to say in my time doing it, there was only one person who was not recommended and it was because they felt he had some violent tendencies. Okay, well, this is taking a turn.
我转录了所有的会议，所有与高管的心理治疗会议。珍娜，这听起来像是一部HBO剧集。天哪。你应该去推销这个。好吧，抱歉，我们跑题了。我想说，在我做这份工作期间，只有一个人没有被推荐，因为他们觉得他有暴力倾向。好吧，这话题变得有点沉重了。
Can you imagine how suspenseful it was for me to be typing out that information? I was like, what are they? 25-year-old Jenna was like, ooh. Yeah, well, that's what I was doing when I was 25. When BJ Novak was 25 years old, he was writing this television show. And this was his first job writing for a television show. I know.
你能想象我打出那些信息时有多紧张吗？我心想，他们是什么人？25岁的珍娜心想，哦。是的，这就是我25岁时在做的事。当BJ·诺瓦克25岁时，他在写这部电视剧。这是他第一份电视编剧工作。我知道。
And his first script was Diversity Day. What the hell is going on? BJ, just settle down on being such an achiever, okay? Can you just relax? I had to reach out to B.J. because I wanted to ask him, B.J., what was it like? Because here we had the British version of the show that was so acclaimed, and you are now tasked with writing the first original episode. The pilot after the pilot. The pilot after the pilot. He explained the original
他的第一个剧本就是《多元化日》。这到底是怎么回事？BJ，别再这么优秀了，好吗？你能放松点吗？我不得不联系BJ，因为我想问他，BJ，那是什么感觉？因为我们有备受赞誉的英版剧集，而你现在被委以重任，编写第一集原创剧集。试播集之后的试播集。试播集之后的试播集。他解释说最初的
writing staff for The Office was Greg Daniels, the executive producer showrunner, Paul Lieberstein, Mindy Kaling, Mike Schurr, and BJ Novak. What a room, by the way. Right? What a room. I know. And then they had Larry Wilmore and Lester Lewis who were consulting. This room full of writers broke down the plots and storylines of the five remaining episodes of season one. And they did this as a group. So they created outlines for each of these episodes. And then a different writer got assigned a different outline and he got assigned the diversity day episode. Okay, so wait, I just want to make sure I understand. So they would take storylines and outlines and break them down as a group. Yes.
《办公室》编剧团队是执行制片人兼剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯、保罗·利伯斯坦、敏迪·卡灵、迈克·舒尔和BJ·诺瓦克。顺便说一句，这阵容太强了。对吧？太强了。我知道。然后他们还有拉里·威尔莫和莱斯特·刘易斯作为顾问。这个编剧室拆解了第一季剩余五集的剧情和故事线。他们是作为一个团队完成的。所以他们为每一集都创建了大纲。然后不同的编剧被分配到不同的大纲，他被分配到了《多元化日》这一集。好的，等等，我只是想确保我理解了。所以他们会把故事线和大纲作为一个团队来拆解。是的。
And then you would get assigned which storyline was yours. Yes. And then you had to fill in the dialogue and different story points. And you know, you do a good amount of writing on your episode. But the idea for the episode comes from the group collective. From the room. Okay. Right.
然后你会被分配到属于你的故事线。是的。然后你必须填补对话和不同的故事点。你知道，你在你的剧集上做了大量的写作工作。但剧集的想法来自集体。来自编剧室。好的。没错。
And also at that time, they didn't know what order they were gonna air. So he did not have the... Pressure. Yes. Of writing the first one. Yeah. That would be so much pressure. I would freeze up. And I remember that.
而且当时他们不知道播出顺序。所以他没有那种……压力。是的。写第一集的压力。是的。那压力太大了。我会僵住的。我记得。
I remember that when we came back after getting picked up and we were gonna shoot these five additional episodes, we had five completed scripts. And then they decided which one they were gonna shoot these five additional episodes, we had five completed scripts. And then they decided which one they were gonna shoot. They didn't come out weekly, they did it collectively before we started the season. Which, I guess that takes some of the pressure off. It would.
我记得当我们被续订回来拍摄这五集额外剧集时，我们有五个完整的剧本。然后他们决定拍摄哪一个。他们不是每周出来的，而是在我们开始这一季之前集体完成的。这我想减轻了一些压力。确实会。
Yeah. And I have another fast fact. All right, you do your fast facts, because I've got some delicious note cards waiting for you. All right. Some Kinsey tidbits over here. I've got some delicious note cards waiting for you. All right. Some Kinsey tidbits over here. I enjoy digesting your note cards. Oh, okay.
是的。我还有一个速记事实。好的，你先说你的速记事实，因为我为你准备了一些美味的笔记卡。好的。这里有一些金赛小贴士。我为你准备了一些美味的笔记卡。好的。这里有一些金赛小贴士。我喜欢消化你的笔记卡。哦，好的。
Digest this first though. What? A lot of people wanna know where did the idea for this episode come from? This episode is based on the real life experience of our writer's assistant, Tom. So when they were in that writer's room, they throw out ideas for episodes.
先消化这个。什么？很多人想知道这一集的灵感来自哪里？这一集是基于我们编剧助理汤姆的真实生活经历。所以当他们在编剧室时，他们会抛出剧集的想法。
And Tom told this story about how when he was in college, he took a class and in the class, they did this exercise where they had to put note cards on their heads that said different ethnicities. And then they had to go around and regard one another as that ethnicity using stereotypes. Where did he go to school? Oh my gosh. I don't know.
汤姆讲了这个故事，说他在大学时上了一门课，在课上，他们做了一个练习，必须在头上贴上写着不同种族的笔记卡。然后他们必须四处走动，使用刻板印象将彼此视为那个种族。他去哪上学？天哪。我不知道。
Holy moly. But that happened. Okay. So let that sink in. Yeah. That happened to people. That happened. Well, here's the thing I feel like about the show and listen, you guys watch it, you know,
天哪。但这确实发生了。好的。让它沉淀一下。是的。那发生在人们身上。那确实发生了。好吧，关于这部剧，我觉得是这样的，听着，你们看它，你们知道，
there's a lot that happens that you're like, oh yeah, that's something like that kind of happened at my job. Yeah. I mean, we had, I worked, when I worked at 1-800-Dennis, we had to go to these human resource, like, like resources meetings and they would act out skits for us about inappropriate behavior. Well, you know what? Remember, we used to have to sit through those sexual harassment seminars on the office. The whole cast and crew would gather in the warehouse and once a year we had to get...
发生了很多事，你会觉得，哦，是的，类似的事情在我的工作中也发生过。是的。我的意思是，我工作时，当我在1-800-DENTIST工作时，我们必须参加这些人力资源会议，他们会为我们表演关于不当行为的小品。好吧，你知道吗？记得我们以前必须坐在《办公室》里参加那些性骚扰研讨会吗？整个演职人员都会聚集在仓库里，一年一次，我们必须……
NBC made us do it. Yeah, made us do sexual harassment training. And then we signed papers saying we'd all behave appropriately at work. Correct. But do you remember what happened in season four or five? The video package that they showed us- Was our show of what not to do.
NBC强迫我们做的。是的，强迫我们进行性骚扰培训。然后我们签署文件，说我们都会在工作中表现得当。没错。但你还记得第四季或第五季发生了什么吗？他们给我们看的视频片段——是我们剧集里关于什么不该做的例子。
Yes, we're clips from the office. We were sitting there watching clips of our show as examples of ways not to behave in a workplace. I've had actually a lot of people tell me that that it comes up in different ways in their either college or work that our show is like what not to do. All right, I've got one more fast fact.
是的，是我们剧集的片段。我们坐在那里看着我们剧集的片段，作为职场中不该有的行为示例。实际上很多人告诉我，在他们的大学或工作中，我们的剧集被当作反面教材。好的，我还有一个速记事实。
And I also have a fan question. Well, okay, good. Cause then I have some Kinsey tidbits. Very good. What would you like first, the fast fact or the fan question? Jenna, what is happening? Are you going out of order? Who are you? You're right. What am I saying? I, the fast fact or the fan question? Jenna, what is happening? Are you going out of order?
我还有一个粉丝提问。好吧，好的。因为我还有一些金赛小贴士。非常好。你先想要什么，速记事实还是粉丝提问？珍娜，发生什么了？你要不按顺序来吗？你是谁？你说得对。我在说什么？我，速记事实还是粉丝提问？珍娜，发生什么了？你要不按顺序来吗？
Who are you? You're right. What am I saying? I want the fast fact. Of course. Finish fast facts. And then go to fan questions. I'm sorry.
你是谁？你说得对。我在说什么？我想要速记事实。当然。完成速记事实。然后进入粉丝提问。抱歉。
I'm feeling very loosey goosey today, obviously. All right. Oh my gosh. Final fast fact. In this episode, we introduce two new characters. Yes we do. Toby Flenderson and Kelly Kapoor played by two more members of our writing staff, Paul Lieberstein and Mindy Kaling.
我今天感觉非常随意，显然。好的。天哪。最后一个速记事实。在这一集中，我们引入了两个新角色。是的，我们引入了。托比·弗兰德森和凯莉·卡普尔，由我们编剧团队的另外两名成员保罗·利伯斯坦和敏迪·卡灵饰演。
Yes, I do have to say, I love the name Toby Flenderson. I love when a character's name sort of describes the character, but like the name Toby Flenderson, like when you see Paul on screen as Toby, you're like, oh, of course that's Toby Flinderson. That's who that is. Absolutely perfect. A lot of people ask why were so many writers actors on the show.
是的，我不得不说，我喜欢托比·弗兰德森这个名字。我喜欢角色的名字能描述角色的感觉，但像托比·弗兰德森这个名字，当你看到保罗在屏幕上饰演托比时，你会觉得，哦，当然那是托比·弗兰德森。就是那个人。绝对完美。很多人问为什么剧里有这么多编剧演员。
And that was Greg Daniels. Greg believed that it would be a good idea for writers to have the experience of acting because it would give them a deeper appreciation of what an actor does, which I have to say is so brilliant. And I think there are a lot of directors that I know go take acting classes, just so they can better speak to actors and understand actors. And it completely worked on our show
那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格认为让编剧有表演经验是个好主意，因为这会让他们更深刻地理解演员的工作，我不得不说这太天才了。而且我认为我知道很多导演去上表演课，只是为了能更好地与演员沟通并理解演员。这在我们的剧集中完全奏效了
that the writers were immersed with us because they really got to not just understand our jobs, but they got to see us being our characters firsthand. They got to see our little improvisations that they would never see if they were just stuck up in the writer's room. And all of that ended up becoming a part of the show. I think it was so great.
编剧们与我们沉浸在一起，因为他们不仅真正理解了我们的工作，还亲眼看到了我们塑造角色的过程。他们看到了我们的小即兴发挥，如果他们只是被困在编剧室里，他们永远也看不到。所有这些最终都成为了剧集的一部分。我觉得这太棒了。
It really made us a cohesive show between the two departments, sort of the writers, the actors, this creative partnership. It always felt like a partnership to me and made me feel safe, like I could try things, you know? But you know, BJ and Mindy were really great performers. They were crossovers, but Paul was not a performer. Paul had only just been a writer. So I know this was like a huge sort of like step out of his comfort zone. And I think he thought it was going to be just this one little line in this episode.
这确实使我们成为两个部门之间紧密结合的剧组，编剧、演员，这种创造性的伙伴关系。对我来说，这感觉总是一种伙伴关系，让我感到安全，就像我可以尝试一些事情，你知道吗？但你知道，BJ和敏迪是非常出色的表演者。他们是跨界者，但保罗不是表演者。保罗只是个编剧。所以我知道这对他来说就像是走出舒适区的一大步。而且我想他以为这在这一集中只是一个小台词。
Right. Well, Jenna texted him this morning. I did. And was like, Paul, tell us the dish on how you became Toby. And he just said, Greg kind of made me do it. He said he remembered walking in one day and it had been decided that he was gonna play this role of Toby. And he really thought it was just gonna be this one line. Right, he didn't think he was gonna be a series regular. Regular, right.
没错。好吧，珍娜今天早上给他发了短信。我发了。问他，保罗，告诉我们你是怎么成为托比的。他只是说，格雷格强迫我这么做的。他说他记得有一天走进去，决定了他要扮演托比这个角色。他真的以为这只是一句台词。没错，他没想过他会成为常规演员。常规，对吧。
No, he did not think it was gonna grow into what it was. But Kevin Reilly, who was the head of NBC at the time, saw this episode. He loved it. He loved the dynamic between Michael Scott and Toby Flenderson. And he said, I want more of that. I want more Toby.
不，他没想过它会发展成现在这样。但当时NBC的负责人凯文·赖利看了这一集。他很喜欢。他喜欢迈克尔·斯科特和托比·弗兰德森之间的化学反应。他说，我想要更多。我想要更多托比。
And so then Paul officially became an actor on the show. Paul was not a performer and he was kind of a quiet person in real life, all of a sudden became a full-time actor and writer. I think something we have to talk about too is the transformation of Kelly Kapoor. A lot of fans wrote in asking about this and I'm sure you've got a note card about it, Angela.
于是保罗正式成为了剧中的演员。保罗不是表演者，他在现实生活中是个安静的人，突然变成了一个全职演员和编剧。我想我们也必须谈谈凯莉·卡普尔的转变。很多粉丝写信问这件事，我相信你有一张关于它的笔记卡，安吉拉。
I do. First of all, all my note cards today are green and Jenna has already said they're horish, but whatever, Jenna. So I have a note card that's just written Kelly's outfit. Yeah. Exclamation point, because this is hilarious. Anyone that knows Mindy knows that after this episode,
我有。首先，我今天所有的笔记卡都是绿色的，珍娜已经说它们很俗气了，但随便吧，珍娜。所以我有一张笔记卡上只写着“凯莉的服装”。是的。感叹号，因为这太搞笑了。任何认识敏迪的人都知道，在这一集之后，
she was like, yeah, I'm not gonna dress like that, okay? Because she had on this sort of paisley blouse and those pants. That went all the way up to her neck. I know, and her hair up in an updo. And it was just so funny to me. Very fussy. Very fussy and sort of just buttoned up.
她说，是的，我不会那样穿，好吗？因为她穿了那种佩斯利花纹的衬衫和那些裤子。一直到她的脖子。我知道，她的头发盘了起来。这对我来说太搞笑了。非常繁琐。非常繁琐，而且有点扣得严严实实。
And right after this episode, I feel like she was like, yeah, I'm going to come in for a real wardrobe fitting and we're going to change up the way Kelly Kapoor looks. I think when she realized, same as Paul, that this was going to be more than just a one-off, that she would be appearing regularly on the show, not only did her wardrobe change, but the whole conceit of her character changed. And she started writing herself more into the character, the love of Beyonce and the clothes and the fashion show, fashion show,
在这一集之后，我觉得她就像是，是的，我要去进行真正的服装试穿，我们要改变凯莉·卡普尔的样子。我想当她意识到，和保罗一样，这不仅仅是一次性的，她会定期出现在剧中，不仅她的衣着变了，而且她角色的整个构思也变了。她开始把自己更多地写进角色里，对碧昂丝的热爱，衣服，还有午餐时的时装秀，时装秀，
fashion show at lunch. And then all Mindy. The romance with BJ. Yes, exactly. Correct. All of those elements sort of weaved their way into the show, But it is true in this first incarnation of Kelly Kapoor, she is very different. Not the Kelly we eventually
时装秀。全是敏迪。与BJ的浪漫。是的，没错。所有这些元素都融入了剧中，但在凯莉·卡普尔的第一个版本中，她确实非常不同。不是我们最终
learned to love. And I love the Kelly she became though, because she was so fun and just added so much like sort of like just sunshine to like whatever scene she was in. I don't know how to say it, but like there was always she was just all so bubbly and everything and everyone else was so drab. So I thought she added much needed energy. She added literal color. Yeah, she was the only person who dressed literally colorfully. So do you want my fan question? Do I? Okay. Heather from Twitter asked, Hi Heather. Hi Heather. Heather asked, since it was only the second episode, what was the atmosphere on set like filming?
学会去爱的那个凯莉。但我喜欢她后来变成的那个凯莉，因为她太有趣了，给无论什么场景都增添了阳光。我不知道怎么说，但她总是那么活泼，而其他人却那么沉闷。所以我认为她增添了急需的活力。她增添了真正的色彩。是的，她是唯一一个穿得真正多彩的人。那么你想要我的粉丝提问吗？我想要吗？好的。来自Twitter的希瑟问，嗨希瑟。嗨希瑟。希瑟问，因为这只是第二集，拍摄时的片场氛围如何？
And I thought that was a really good question because we shot Diversity Day about six months after we shot the pilot. We took this really long break because we were waiting to find out if we were going to get picked up or not. And it was so thrilling to be reunited again. I remember when we were watching Diversity Day, people have asked me, when did you feel
我觉得这是一个很好的问题，因为我们在拍摄试播集大约六个月后拍摄了《多元化日》。我们休息了很长一段时间，因为我们在等看是否会被续订。再次重聚真是太激动人心了。我记得当我们看《多元化日》时，人们问我，你什么时候觉得
like you had a hit? And I said, it's the moment we were all in the room and we all had those note cards taped to our foreheads. And I was just looking around at all of us and Steve was being Michael and he was being so hilarious. And I thought, oh my God, if we can just get anyone to watch the show, we're gonna be hit.
你成功了？我说，就是我们都在房间里，额头上贴着那些笔记卡的那一刻。我环顾四周，史蒂夫在扮演迈克尔，他太搞笑了。我想，天哪，如果我们能让任何人看这部剧，我们就会成功。
If anyone sees it, it's so good. And it really was in that moment, I was like, oh wow, this is lightning in a bottle. Now how do we get the world to watch it? Aw, I love that, Ange. Listen, should we take a break? Yeah, let's take a break. I have lots of note cards. Aw, I love that, Ange. Listen, should we take a break? Yeah, let's take a break. I have lots of note cards.
如果有人看到它，它太棒了。真的就在那一刻，我心想，哦，哇，这真是瓶子里的闪电。现在我们如何让全世界看它？哦，我喜欢那个，安吉。听着，我们要休息一下吗？是的，休息一下吧。我有很多笔记卡。哦，我喜欢那个，安吉。听着，我们要休息一下吗？是的，休息一下吧。我有很多笔记卡。
Well, perfect. When we come back, we will really break down Diversity Day and get into the scenes and tell you all our stories. You say diversity. I say diversity. What? Yeah, it's just been bugging me.
好吧，完美。回来后，我们将真正解析《多元化日》，深入场景并告诉你们我们所有的故事。你说多元化。我说多元化。什么？是的，它一直困扰着我。
But anyway. Diversity? OK, let's go to our break. Ha, ha, ha. Okay, let's go to our break. You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it. Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon, or they could be late for the bus. You never know. Ambition is on the inside. So that road trip bucket list?
但不管怎样。多元化？好的，我们去休息一下。哈哈。好的，我们去休息一下。你知道雄心壮志有什么好吗？你看不见它。有些事情看起来雄心勃勃，但外表可能是骗人的。例如，一个跑步者可能在为马拉松训练，或者他们可能赶不上公交车。你永远不知道。雄心壮志在内心。那么那个公路旅行愿望清单呢？
Get after it. Drive your ambition. Mitsubishi Motors. As a Fizz member, you can look forward to free data, big savings on plans, and having your unused data roll over to the following month, every month. At Fizz, you always get more for your money. Terms and conditions for our different programs and policies apply. Details at fizz.ca. Finance podcasters love saying things like, If you don't cook every single meal at home, well, good luck retiring. At Wealthsimple, we know that's not true.
去实现它吧。驱动你的雄心。三菱汽车。作为Fizz会员，你可以期待免费数据、计划大额节省，并将未使用的流量结转到下个月，每个月都是如此。在Fizz，你总是能物超所值。我们不同计划和政策的条款与条件适用。详情请见fizz.ca。金融播客喜欢说这样的话，如果你不每顿饭都在家做，好吧，祝你退休好运。在Wealthsimple，我们知道那不是真的。
Building wealth takes time. You deserve to live a little while you wait. That's why we're introducing new rewards, like right. So the Diversity Day episode starts with Michael explaining that today's diversity day is a day where you can get to know your peers better. And Michael is going to talk about the benefits of diversity day. So, if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the
积累财富需要时间。你在等待的同时也应该享受生活。这就是为什么我们引入了新的奖励，比如对。所以《多元化日》这一集开始于迈克尔解释说今天的多元化日是一个你可以更好地了解同伴的日子。迈克尔将谈论多元化日的好处。所以，如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的
website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the
网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的
website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsimple.com. And if you're interested in learning more about diversity day, you can check out the website at wealthsim back. Hello. All right. So the Diversity Day episode starts with Michael explaining that today the office is having
网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsimple.com。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于多元化日的信息，你可以查看网站wealthsim回来。你好。好的。所以《多元化日》这一集开始于迈克尔解释说今天办公室正在进行
a mandatory diversity training. We also learned that today is the day that Jim is going to make his biggest sale of the year. He explains he only has to make one phone call and it amounts to 25% of his total sales for the year. But Dwight keeps making it impossible for him to make one phone call and it amounts to 25% of his total sales for the year, but Dwight keeps making it impossible for him to make that call. And so the first way that Dwight makes it impossible for him to make this phone call
强制性的多元化培训。我们还了解到，今天吉姆要完成他今年最大的一笔销售。他解释说，他只需要打一个电话，这笔交易就占了他全年总销售额的25%。但德怀特一直让他无法打那个电话，这占了他全年总销售额的25%，但德怀特一直让他无法打那个电话。所以德怀特让他无法打这个电话的第一个方法
is that he must shred paper at his desk. Oh, Dwight. Which I always thought was funny because, you know, Pam has that industrial size shredder behind her desk. Pam has a shredder like the size of a Xerox machine behind her desk. Yeah, which we never use. Never use. Ever. I never shredded a single thing in it. And it used to get in the way when the camera... You had to move it. And it was a big argument over whether or not they could move it. Like the integrity of the documentary crew,
就是让他必须在办公桌前碎纸。哦，德怀特。我一直觉得这很有趣，因为你知道，帕姆的办公桌后面有那个工业级的碎纸机。帕姆的办公桌后面有一个像施乐复印机那么大的碎纸机。是的，我们从来不用。从来不用。一次都没用过。我从来没用它碎过任何东西。而且它过去常常挡路，当摄像机……你必须把它移开。关于能不能移开它，曾有过一场大争论。就像纪录片摄制组的完整性，
would they have moved the industrial shredder or not. And so I remember a day we were on set and they wanted to get this shot behind my desk. And they said, if we could just move the shredder, we could get the shot you're asking for. And it was like a 30 minute argument over whether or not they could move or not move the shredder. Right. Because they didn't want to like ruin the integrity of the documentary. Yes. This was a big thing all the time. They decided you can't move walls, you can't move windows, you can't move furniture.
他们到底会不会移走那个工业碎纸机。我记得有一天我们在片场，他们想在我办公桌后面拍这个镜头。他们说，如果我们能把碎纸机移开，我们就能拍到你想要的镜头。关于能不能移开碎纸机，他们争论了大约30分钟。对。因为他们不想破坏纪录片的完整性。是的。这一直是个大问题。他们决定你不能移动墙壁，不能移动窗户，不能移动家具。
They did agree you could move this one plant around. Also, they clearly agreed that you could move that conference table out and put chairs, and then all of a sudden the conference table would be back. Where did the conference table would be back. I've had- Where did the conference table go? Where did the conference table go? I know.
他们确实同意你可以移动这盆植物。此外，他们显然同意你可以把那张会议桌搬走，放上椅子，然后突然间会议桌又会回来。会议桌去哪了？会议桌又回来了。我曾——会议桌去哪了？会议桌去哪了？我知道。
I've had so many people write to me on social media be like, what happened with the conference table? It was there and then it's gone. Where does the conference table go? And I told them, I said, you know what I would have loved at the end of one episode, all it would take is one episode and the whole nine seasons, if at the end credits, it just showed like Kevin and like Jim breaking down the conference table and Dwight and like stacking it in some storage thing and then having to go get it and put it back together. But just as the credits rolled. Yes, I would love to see them carrying the
有很多人在社交媒体上写信问我，会议桌怎么了？它在那儿，然后又不见了。会议桌去哪了？我告诉他们，我说，你知道吗，我本来希望在某一集的结尾，只需要一集，在九季的结尾，如果片尾字幕显示凯文和吉姆拆掉会议桌，德怀特把它堆在某个储藏室里，然后又不得不去把它拿回来重新组装。就在片尾字幕滚动的时候。是的，我很想看到他们把
conference table down to the warehouse or something. Like in pieces. Because where is it? I don't know. There is nowhere for it to be. I don't know. That is one of the great mysteries of the show. Where is the conference table? Every time Michael was like, conference room meeting, that they were like, ugh, because they knew they had to break down that table. Okay, okay.
会议桌搬到仓库或者什么地方。就像拆成碎片一样。因为它在哪？我不知道。它没地方可去。我不知道。这是该剧的一大谜团。会议桌在哪？每次迈克尔说，会议室开会，他们就说，呃，因为他们知道他们得拆掉那张桌子。好吧，好吧。
Well, do you remember that shredding scene where Rain is shredding the paper? Yes. And so he's shredding paper, he's shredding paper. So then Rain notices that there's a special slot on his personal shredder for a credit card and he kind of stopped the filming and he said, guys, I think I should shred a credit card.
那么，你还记得雷恩碎纸的那场戏吗？记得。所以他在碎纸，他在碎纸。然后雷恩注意到他的个人碎纸机上有一个专门放信用卡的插槽，他有点停止了拍摄，他说，伙计们，我觉得我应该碎一张信用卡。
And we were thinking, well, okay. And he said, no, there's a special slot for it. I know, everyone was like, is it gonna work? And so he did it. He did it. They got him like a fake like credit card, the props department and he did it but it almost broke that shredder. It started going like, I remember sitting there and thinking, is it, you know, is it what's happening? What's happening? But he was so determined. I also think Rain is
我们当时想，好吧，好吧。他说，不，这里有个专门的插槽。我知道，每个人都在想，它会起作用吗？于是他做了。他做了。道具组给了他一张假信用卡，他照做了，但那差点弄坏了碎纸机。它开始发出那种声音，我记得我坐在那儿想，它，你知道，发生了什么？发生了什么？但他太坚决了。我也觉得雷恩
like a gadget person a little bit. So he was like, oh, there's a thing on here. I need to do it. Yeah, I need to work this part of the machine. I need to do it. Angela, would you like to do a card? I would, Jenna Fisher. Okay, so this card applies to the opening shot of the whole episode.
有点像个小玩意儿爱好者。所以他当时想，哦，这上面有个东西。我得试试。是的，我得操作机器的这个部分。我得试试。安吉拉，你想试一张卡吗？我想，珍娜·费舍尔。好吧，所以这张卡适用于整集的开场镜头。
There is a great establishing shot of the Homer Simpson doll. The camera is going past Phyllis's desk and it's sitting right there. And you know, it just makes me smile because I know that Greg Daniels wrote on The Simpsons and this was his little like nod to like the first part of his career, right?
有一个很棒的辛普森一家玩偶的定场镜头。摄像机经过菲利斯的办公桌，它就坐在那儿。你知道，这让我微笑，因为我知道格雷格·丹尼尔斯曾为《辛普森一家》写过剧本，这是他对职业生涯早期的一点致敬，对吧？
Yes. And it sat there all nine years. It did. That Simpson doll. So I love that. That's just like kind of dorky moment. You guys know I love the things in the background. Well, you know what he did for the main cast. I'm sorry.
是的。它在那里坐了整整九年。确实。那个辛普森玩偶。所以我很喜欢。那只是那种书呆子气的时刻。你们知道我喜欢背景里的东西。好吧，你知道他为主要演员做了什么吗？抱歉。
I do know this. You do know. Are you saying I'm sorry because I didn't get one? Yeah. Because you're calling me not main cast? Well, we called you supporting cast. Is this... As a gift. You guys, the rest of us didn't become series regular till Boo's Cruise. That's story for later. But in the beginning, the main... There were just rest of us didn't become series regular till Boo's Cruise, that's story for later. But in the beginning, the main- There were just five of us.
我知道这件事。你知道。你是说我抱歉是因为我没得到一个吗？是的。因为你称我不是主要演员？好吧，我们称你为配角。这是……作为礼物。你们，我们其他人直到《Boo's Cruise》那一集才成为常规演员。那是后话了。但起初，主要的……只有我们其他人直到《Boo's Cruise》才成为常规演员，那是后话了。但起初，主要的——只有我们五个。
Well, there weren't just the five of you, but you were the five that were the quote, series regulars. That's right, there were just the five series regulars, I should say. And the rest of us were just trash in the corner. No, but we had to do a lot of extra stuff. You had to do press and whatnot. We had to do press and we had to do a lot of extra stuff. You had to do press and whatnot.
好吧，不仅仅是你们五个，但你们是那五个所谓的“常规演员”。没错，应该说只有那五个常规演员。而我们其他人只是角落里的垃圾。不，但我们必须做很多额外的工作。你们必须做媒体宣传之类的。我们必须做媒体宣传，我们必须做很多额外的工作。你们必须做媒体宣传之类的。
We had to do press and we had to do these crazy photo shoots and we did all this stuff as the show was launching. Listen, there is no debating. You guys were the core main cast and the rest of us filled out the picture and then it grew and then the cast grew and then we had all of these series regulars. But I'm going to give you a little shit. And you can leave that in, Sam. I'm gonna give you a little shiitake sometimes.
我们必须做媒体宣传，我们必须做这些疯狂的照片拍摄，在剧集推出时我们做了所有这些事情。听着，这没什么好争论的。你们是核心主要演员，我们其他人填补了画面，然后它成长了，演员阵容也扩大了，然后我们有了所有这些常规演员。但我还是要给你一点小麻烦。你可以把它留着，萨姆。我有时会给你一点小麻烦。
All right, listen. So, as a gift, Greg had the illustrators over at the Simpsons turn us all into Simpsons characters. all into Simpson characters. And it was me, John, Rain, and Steve huddled around a computer. Now that I'm saying it, I realize I think BJ Novak was left out of this photo. Sorry, BJ. But we were Simpsonized. And he gave us these illustrations in like a frame.
好吧，听着。所以，作为礼物，格雷格让《辛普森一家》的插画家把我们所有人都变成了辛普森角色。所有人都变成了辛普森角色。我和约翰、雷恩、史蒂夫挤在电脑前。现在我说出来才意识到，我想BJ·诺瓦克没在这张照片里。抱歉，BJ。但我们被“辛普森化”了。他把这些插图装在相框里送给了我们。
It's really cool. It's really cool. It's in my living room. It's like a treasured item from the show. Jenna is a Simpson. I have a Simpson version of me. All right, I wanna talk about Pam's free sell and so does BNG Chris on Twitter.
真的很酷。真的很酷。它在我的客厅里。这是来自该剧的珍藏品。珍娜是一个辛普森人。我有一个辛普森版本的我。好吧，我想谈谈帕姆的空当接龙，推特上的BNG Chris也想谈。
Well, let's hear it BNG Chris. All right, he asked if we were actually good at free sell. And the answer is, oh yes, we were. You want to know why? This is one of my note cards too. We didn't get Wi-Fi until July of 2006. And it was such a big deal on our set that a memo went around and I saved the memo. It was because for it to give you some context, we shot this episode in 2004.
好吧，让我们听听BNG Chris怎么说。好吧，他问我们是否真的擅长空当接龙。答案是，哦，是的，我们确实擅长。你想知道为什么吗？这也是我的笔记卡之一。直到2006年7月我们才用上Wi-Fi。这在我们的片场是一件大事，以至于传阅了一份备忘录，我保存了那份备忘录。这是因为为了给你一些背景信息，我们在2004年拍摄了这一集。
Yes, and so it wasn't until 2006 that we got internet. So for the pilot, they were nothing. They were literally like pieces of plastic. I have to tell you something, Angela. My computer on the pilot was real. Son of a b***h, Jenna. I'm so sorry. Maincast got real computers. Shut up! Are you serious? You and John and Rain had actual computers?
是的，所以直到2006年我们才有了互联网。所以对于试播集，它们什么都不是。它们简直就像塑料片。我得告诉你一件事，安吉拉。我在试播集里的电脑是真的。该死的，珍娜。我很抱歉。主要演员有真正的电脑。闭嘴！你是认真的吗？你、约翰和雷恩有真正的电脑？
No internet, but you had games for the pilot? Yeah. Will this ever end? Will it ever end? All these things I'm learning. Well, back in accounting, guys, we had a piece of plastic that they made look like a computer.
没有互联网，但你们在试播集里有游戏？是的。这会结束吗？这会结束吗？所有这些我正在学习的事情。好吧，回到会计部，伙计们，我们有一块塑料片，他们让它看起来像一台电脑。
You just had to stare at a plastic box. Piece of plastic that did nothing, so we passed notes. I haven't known when to tell you this because you've told the story before that our computer. And you have sat silent? I haven't known how to tell you that all along I had a real computer. Oh my God, what else is gonna come out in this podcast?
你只能盯着一个塑料盒。什么都没做的塑料片，所以我们传纸条。我一直不知道什么时候该告诉你这件事，因为你以前讲过那个故事，关于我们的电脑。而你一直保持沉默？我一直不知道该怎么告诉你，我一直有一台真正的电脑。天哪，这个播客里还会爆出什么？
I don't know. Holy crap. Well, we passed a lot of notes and I saved those too. Oscar can draw. He's a really good drawer and he would draw me and Brian as Kevin and Angela and I saved them all. So there, Jenna. That's what you were doing while I was on my actual computer.
我不知道。天哪。好吧，我们传了很多纸条，我也保存了那些。奥斯卡会画画。他画得非常好，他会画我和布莱恩作为凯文和安吉拉，我把它们都保存了下来。所以，珍娜。这就是当我在用我的真实电脑时你在做的事情。
Well, whatever. The answer to that story is yes, we were very good at solitaire because it's all we had to do for like two years. It's true. And we had on-set free-sell competitions. And we would compete with the cast and crew. In between scenes, the crew would sit down at a desk and they would play free-sell.
好吧，随便吧。那个故事的答案是，是的，我们非常擅长空当接龙，因为那是我们两年来唯一能做的事情。这是真的。我们还在片场举行过空当接龙比赛。我们会和演员及工作人员竞争。在拍摄间隙，工作人员会坐在桌子旁玩空当接龙。
And Kate Flannery held the title for a very long time. She was really very good. She is a master. Phyllis was also very good. Kate is so good, though. Yes. With the free-sell, the competition was who could do it in the so good though. Yes, with the free sell, the competition was who could do it in the fewest moves.
凯特·弗兰纳里保持了很长时间的冠军头衔。她真的很擅长。她是大师。菲利斯也非常擅长。不过凯特真的很厉害。是的。关于空当接龙，比赛是谁能用最少的步数完成。
And yeah. Kate was really good. I never made the top 10. I would also lose patience. Okay, all right, get going. What else you got over there, Fisher? What else are you hiding from me that you're not telling me?
是的。凯特真的很厉害。我从来没进过前十名。我也会失去耐心。好吧，好吧，继续吧。你那边还有什么，费舍尔？你还瞒着我什么没告诉我？
What other perks did you have? Well, this wasn't really a perk, but this was a little sneaky. So during this episode, off camera, there was a whole thing going on and it involved me and Phyllis. So Phyllis and I are from St. Louis, Missouri. And during this time, the Cardinals were in the playoffs. I remember this. They ended up in the World Series
你还有什么额外福利？好吧，这不算真正的福利，但这有点鬼鬼祟祟。所以在那一集拍摄期间，在镜头外，发生了一整件事，涉及我和菲利斯。所以菲利斯和我来自密苏里州圣路易斯。在那段时间，红雀队在季后赛。我记得这个。他们最终进入了世界大赛
against the Boston Red Sox. And in between scenes, Phyllis and I would sneak back to my trailer and watch the Cardinals games. Yes. And we were rooting hard for the Cardinals. And it was very difficult for us because basically, everyone else on the set was from Boston. Steve, BJ, John, more people.
对阵波士顿红袜队。在拍摄间隙，菲利斯和我溜回我的拖车看红雀队的比赛。是的。我们非常支持红雀队。这对我们来说非常困难，因为基本上，片场里的其他人都是波士顿人。史蒂夫、BJ、约翰，还有更多人。
Everyone was reading for the Red Sox except for me and Phyllis. And the really- I wrote it for the Cardinals with you. Do you remember that? You don't remember that? No. Jenna, you and I are gonna have a talk after this, lady. Well, I did. You brought me onto your side.
除了我和菲利斯，每个人都在为红袜队加油。真的——我和你一起为红雀队加油。你记得吗？你不记得了吗？不。珍娜，这件事之后我们要谈谈，女士。好吧，我确实记得。你把我拉到了你这边。
One of, I, listen, one of the things I remember so distinctly about that World Series is that at the end of work, we would stay and we would all go into John's trailer and we would watch the game. Angela, if you were in John's trailer, you were rooting for Boston. Oh. Phyllis and I watched it in my trailer.
听着，关于那届世界大赛，我记得最清楚的一件事是，工作结束后，我们会留下来，我们都会去约翰的拖车里看比赛。安吉拉，如果你在约翰的拖车里，你就是在为波士顿加油。哦。菲利斯和我在我的拖车里看。
Wait, I didn't know that, wait, you weren't, oh right, you didn't go and draw. No. Oh. We were in island, Phyllis and I. We were in island. Well John's trailer was really fun. A lot of people were in there. Of course they were.
等等，我不知道那个，等等，你没去，哦对了，你没去。不。哦。我们在孤岛上，菲利斯和我。我们在孤岛上。好吧，约翰的拖车真的很有趣。很多人都在里面。当然他们都在。
I think I probably stopped by your trailer and was like, brr, brr. It's a little sad in here. And I went into the party trailer where everyone was gathered. Well, also Boston swept the series 4 to 0. So it was a particularly depressing room. I mean, I remember there being snacks and laughter. Phyllis and I were just in my trailer crying. OK, maybe I didn't realize that.
我想我可能去过你的拖车，当时说，呜呜，呜呜。这里有点悲伤。然后我去了大家聚集的派对拖车。好吧，而且波士顿以4比0横扫了系列赛。所以那是一个特别令人沮丧的房间。我的意思是，我记得那里有零食和笑声。菲利斯和我在我的拖车里哭。好吧，也许我没意识到这一点。
No big deal. OK. All right, we should really get back to the meat of this episode. Oh my god, you guys, I'm sorry. We've gone on so many tangents. This is what happens when we get together. OK, back to the meat of this episode. Oh my god, you guys, I'm sorry. We've gone on so many tangents. This is what happens when we get together. OK, back to diversity day.
没什么大不了的。好吧。好吧，我们真的应该回到这一集的重点了。天哪，伙计们，我很抱歉。我们跑题太多了。这就是我们聚在一起时会发生的事情。好吧，回到这一集的重点。天哪，伙计们，我很抱歉。我们跑题太多了。这就是我们聚在一起时会发生的事情。好吧，回到多元化日。
All right, so Mr. Brown comes into the office to run the diversity training and once again, played by one of the members of the writing staff. So brilliant, Larry Wilmore. Larry Wilmore. So smart, so funny. He originally read the part during a table read. Yes.
好吧，所以布朗先生来到办公室进行多元化培训，他再次由编剧组成员之一扮演。太棒了，拉里·威尔莫。拉里·威尔莫。太聪明，太有趣了。他最初在剧本朗读会上读了这个角色。是的。
Just because they hadn't cast the role yet. They were going to cast the role. They just hadn't gotten to it yet. That's right. Greg loved how he read it so much that he asked Larry to audition because this was a big part. This wasn't just one line. So you had to audition for a role of this size.
只是因为他们还没选定这个角色。他们打算选角。他们只是还没到那一步。没错。格雷格非常喜欢他的朗读方式，以至于他要求拉里去试镜，因为这是一个大角色。这不仅仅是一句台词。所以你必须为这样一个角色试镜。
So they put him through the paces. Poor guy. But what I loved about his deliveries, it was so straight. He did it like so straight. He put nothing on it, no spin on it. And that's why it worked. But this was not the first time that Larry Wilmore has performed. He was a writer performer. Yes. Did you know he had a recurring role on the Facts of Life? No. Yeah, as a police officer. Somebody did a deep dive on the internet. I did. Want to hear what else the internet told me? Yeah.
所以他们让他经历了考验。可怜的家伙。但我喜欢他的表演方式，非常直白。他演得非常直白。他没有加任何东西，没有加任何修饰。这就是它有效的原因。但这并不是拉里·威尔莫第一次表演。他是一位编剧兼演员。是的。你知道他在《生活点滴》中有个常驻角色吗？不。是的，扮演一名警察。有人在网上进行了深度挖掘。我做了。想听听互联网还告诉了我什么吗？是的。
He created the Bernie Mac show for which he won an Emmy. And he was a Daily Show correspondent. He's very funny. And I actually emailed him. And he wants to come on and chat with us. So. Oh, yes. I know.
他创作了《伯尼·麦克秀》，并因此获得了艾美奖。他还是《每日秀》的记者。他非常有趣。我实际上给他发了邮件。他想来和我们聊天。所以。哦，是的。我知道。
I know. He couldn't do it for this episode. But we're going to get Larry on. I'm so excited. We should. Because I want to get more of that story of exactly how he wound up as Mr. Brown and what it was like for him to do those scenes with Steve.
我知道。他这一集没能来。但我们会请拉里来的。我太兴奋了。我们应该这样做。因为我想了解更多关于他究竟是如何成为布朗先生的故事，以及他和史蒂夫演那些戏是什么感觉。
Oh, with Steve, just like, he was just messing with him all day. And he stayed so stoic. I know. He was great. It was amazing. I have to say this one story about Larry Wilmore. When this show was going to air, he
哦，和史蒂夫在一起，他整天都在捉弄他。而他保持得如此冷静。我知道。他很棒。太神奇了。我必须讲一个关于拉里·威尔莫的故事。当这部剧要播出时，他
invited the whole cast over to watch it at his house. And I had like an apartment at that time. So like anyone that had a house, I was like, Oh my God, you're like the real deal. Yes, you're an adult. You're an adult. Well, that's something we used to do. We used to watch every week together as a cast these viewing parties, I hosted everybody for the pilot. It was before it aired, Greg came over with a DVD of the pilot and the cast piled into my living room. We couldn't figure out how to make it work at first. Do you remember, like your sound wasn't,
邀请了全体演员去他家观看。那时我有个公寓。所以任何有房子的人，我都觉得，天哪，你真是个大人物。是的，你是成年人。你是成年人。好吧，那是我们过去常做的事情。我们过去常作为演员每周聚在一起看这些观看派对，我为试播集招待了所有人。那是在播出之前，格雷格带着试播集的DVD过来，演员们挤在我的客厅里。起初我们不知道怎么让它工作。你记得吗，你的声音没，
like the DVD wasn't working and we were all freaking out? And we had, well, I also remember we had to like move furniture out of the way and people were on the floor. I have a picture of that and there's Steve Carell just sitting on my floor. He didn't get a spot on the couch ready to watch the pilot. I have one just like that. And I remember telling everyone, OK, so my building doesn't have parking. So here I am telling the cast you have to street park.
DVD没法播放，我们都吓坏了？我们不得不，好吧，我还记得我们不得不把家具移开，人们坐在地板上。我有一张那样的照片，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔就坐在我的地板上。他没在沙发上找到位置，准备看试播集。我有一张一模一样的。我记得告诉大家，好吧，我的大楼没有停车位。所以在这里我告诉演员们你们必须在街上停车。
Also, I'm the unit way in the back. It says eight to four, but I'm eight to four and a half. And everyone came. It was like so sweet. And Paul Fiegg used to host a lot. Oh my gosh. Paul and Lori Fiegg, they would put out a fantastic little buffet. They would. They are great hosts. But yes, we used to watch the episodes together as a cast, which is something we did really
而且，我是最里面的单元。上面写着8点到4点，但我的是8点到4点半。每个人都来了。真是太贴心了。保罗·费格过去常做东。天哪。保罗和洛里·费格，他们会准备很棒的小自助餐。他们会。他们是伟大的主人。但是的，我们过去常作为演员一起看剧集，这是我们做了很多年的事情。
for years. For years. Should we take a break? Yes, I think we take a break. And when we come back, Jenna, I have a question about something that's in the background. You know how I love things in the background. You've really been the background spotter of this podcast. I have. You guys-
很多年。我们要休息一下吗？是的，我想我们休息一下。当我们回来时，珍娜，我有一个关于背景里某样东西的问题。你知道我有多喜欢背景里的东西。你真的是这个播客的背景观察员。我是。你们——
As people will hear. As you will hear, because we've done a few of these. Jenna knows I love things in the background. I love things in the background. ["The Star Wars Movie"] Interior Chinatown is an all new series based on the best selling novel by Charles Yu about a struggling Asian actor who gets a bigger part than he expected when he witnesses a
正如人们会听到的。正如你们会听到的，因为我们已经做了几次了。珍娜知道我喜欢背景里的东西。我喜欢背景里的东西。《内陆唐人街》是一部全新的系列剧，改编自查尔斯·余的畅销小说，讲述了一位挣扎的亚裔演员在目睹了一场
crime in Chinatown streaming November 19th only on Disney Plus. Celebrate all the little moments of cheer and togetherness at Starbucks. Pair your peppermint mocha with a cozy game night. Sip your chestnut praline latte at a holiday movie marathon. Or take your caramel brulee latte along on your impromptu catch-up. These are sips worth sharing, so come together and find your holiday magic. Only at Starbucks. Some things require a lot of work to grow, like plants, hair, babies, or your savings.
唐人街的犯罪后，得到了比他预期更大的角色，11月19日仅在Disney Plus独家上线。在星巴克庆祝所有那些欢聚的小时刻。将你的薄荷摩卡与舒适的游戏之夜搭配。在节日电影马拉松中啜饮你的栗子果仁拿铁。或者带着你的焦糖布蕾拿铁去参加即兴聚会。这些都是值得分享的啜饮，所以聚在一起，找到你的节日魔法。仅在星巴克。有些事情需要付出很多努力才能成长，比如植物、头发、婴儿或你的储蓄。
But when you run a business, you already have enough on your plate. Scotiabank's Right Size Savings for Business account can help you grow your savings with ease. For a limited time, open a new account and earn up to 4.65% interest for the first six months. Before you know it, your savings will grow without you even noticing. Ooh, which reminds me, I need a haircut. Conditions apply. Ends December 15th. Rate is annual, calculated daily, and will vary based on account balance. Visit scotiabank.com
但当你经营企业时，你已经够忙了。丰业银行的商业“适度储蓄”账户可以帮助你轻松增加储蓄。在有限的时间内，开设一个新账户，前六个月可赚取高达4.65%的利息。在你意识到之前，你的储蓄就会在不知不觉中增长。哦，这提醒我，我需要理发了。条件适用。12月15日截止。利率为年利率，按日计算，并将根据账户余额而变化。访问scotiabank.com
slash rightsize savings for full details. And we're back. Hello, everyone. Angela, give it to us. What's your observation? Well, I have two. First of all, at six minutes, around 46 seconds, I can make out the yellow Post-It note sprinkles invite that I drew on the partition in Kevin's desk. Really? Yes. We talked about this in the pilot.
斜杠rightsize savings了解详情。我们回来了。大家好。安吉拉，告诉我们。你的观察是什么？好吧，我有两个。首先，在6分46秒左右，我能辨认出我画在凯文办公桌隔板上的黄色便利贴Sprinkles邀请函。真的吗？是的。我们在试播集里谈过这个。
It's a little yellow Post-It note and I can just see the side of it. And it just made me happy because it was there all nine years, as you know, all nine seasons. And then Brian gave it to me and I have it and I love it, but I can spot it. And that just made me happy. So there you go. Sprinkles Post-it note. And here's the second thing I observed at around eight minutes, 30 seconds. There is a cartoon taped to Michael's door with like a notepad with like some writing on it. Okay. That's all I got. What?
那是一张黄色的小便利贴，我只能看到它的一侧。这让我很高兴，因为它在那里待了整整九年，如你所知，整整九季。然后布莱恩把它给了我，我保存着它，我很喜欢它，但我能认出它。这让我很高兴。所以给你。Sprinkles便利贴。这是我观察到的第二件事，在8分30秒左右。迈克尔的门上贴着一张卡通画，上面有个记事本，写着一些字。好吧。这就是我所有的发现。什么？
What is it? What? What is the cartoon? I don't know. I did take a picture of my TV and I zoomed in as big as I could. I don't know what it is. That's it.
是什么？什么？那张卡通画是什么？我不知道。我确实拍了电视机的照片，我尽可能地放大了。我不知道那是什么。就是这样。
That's it. Your observation is that there is a cartoon on Michael's door, the end. Okay, well, the way you're looking at me is a little judgy. They're not all gonna pay off, Jenna. I mean, I thought you were gonna tell me what it was or how it got there, but no. I don't know, but I bet someone else is looking at it
就是这样。你的观察是迈克尔的门上有一张卡通画，结束。好吧，你看着我的方式有点评判性。并不是所有的观察都会有结果，珍娜。我的意思是，我以为你会告诉我那是什么或者它是怎么在那儿的，但没有。我不知道，但我敢打赌还有别人在看它
and being like, Angela, I saw that too. I don't know what it's about. Thank you so much for that one. Moving on. I need to talk about a scene that contains one of my favorite lines of all time from the show. I know it, because it contains one of my favorite lines of all time from the show.
并且会说，安吉拉，我也看到了。我不知道那是关于什么的。非常感谢你的那一个。继续。我需要谈谈一个场景，它包含了剧中我最喜欢的台词之一。我知道，因为它包含了剧中我最喜欢的台词之一。
I know it because it's one of mine. I know it. When Steve does his own diversity training, he makes a video. And in that video, he has a line where he says, Abraham Lincoln once said, if you are a racist, I will attack you with the North. I love that line so much. And I asked BJ who wrote that line, because I know there's a collective element to the
我知道，因为那是我的台词之一。我知道。当史蒂夫做他自己的多元化培训时，他制作了一个视频。在那个视频里，他有一句台词说，亚伯拉罕·林肯曾经说过，如果你是一个种族主义者，我将用北方攻击你。我非常喜欢那句台词。我问BJ是谁写的，因为我知道剧本写作有一个集体元素。
script writing. So the process is they break down the plot and then a single writer goes and writes it. But then they bring that script back to the group and people can pitch jokes. They do joke punch up. Yeah, they can do joke punch up. And BJ said it was Paul Lieberstein. Oh, so smart. And he said that the people in the writer's room thought it might be like too heady of
所以过程是他们拆解情节，然后一个编剧去写。但他们会把剧本带回小组，人们可以提出笑话。他们做笑话润色。是的，他们可以做笑话润色。BJ说是保罗·利伯斯坦。哦，太聪明了。他说编剧室里的人认为这可能是一个太深奥的笑话，或者它可能不会真正奏效。但它不仅奏效了，它还是剧中被引用最多的台词之一，并启发了一个名为“北方攻击”的粉丝网站。
a joke or that it might not really land. But not only did it land, it is one of the most quoted lines from the show and inspired a fansite called Northern Attack. Yes. And it is great. So smart. So great. I also asked BJ about diversity today
是的。这太棒了。太聪明了。太棒了。我还问了BJ关于多元化今天
and diversity tomorrow. And he said that he wrote that, that he wrote diversity, that it was called diversity tomorrow. And he said that he wrote that, that he wrote diversity, that it was called diversity today. And then, you know, Michael calls it diversity tomorrow because today is almost over. But he said his original pitch, which he was very sad to have to lose
和多元化明天。他说他写了那个，他写了多元化，它叫多元化明天。他说他写了那个，他写了多元化，它叫多元化今天。然后，你知道，迈克尔称之为多元化明天，因为今天快结束了。但他说是他最初的提议，他很难过不得不放弃
was that it was actually called diversity 360. And Michael said in his video that he was from Diversity 365 because diversity should never take five days off. But unfortunately, there was a real Diversity 360. And they couldn't clear it because it would have seemed like we were making fun of a real business. So he had to change it to diversity today, diversity tomorrow.
是它实际上叫多元化360。迈克尔在他的视频里说他来自多元化365，因为多元化永远不应该休息五天。但不幸的是，有一个真正的多元化360。他们无法通过审核，因为这看起来像我们在嘲笑一家真正的企业。所以他不得不把它改成多元化今天，多元化明天。
That is so funny. I have a little note card here for you, lady. Give it to me. So there is a moment in the conference room where Jen and I are seated next to each other. And oh, yeah. So we were rarely seated next to each other because we would just start laughing.
那太有趣了。我这里有一张给你的笔记卡，女士。给我。所以会议室里有一个时刻，珍娜和我坐在一起。哦，是的。所以我们很少坐在一起，因为我们会开始大笑。
This is what we discovered pretty early on. But this was an extreme reason why. This was an extreme reason why. So Steve, as Michael, we knew he was going to sit into the scene, but we didn't know exactly how. Like, he hadn't done this in any rehearsals. So here we are, the camera's rolling, and that conference room is small.
这是我们很早就发现的。但这有一个极端的原因。这是一个极端的原因。所以史蒂夫，作为迈克尔，我们知道他会坐进场景里，但我们不知道具体怎么坐。就像，他在任何排练中都没这样做过。所以我们在这儿，摄像机在转动，那个会议室很小。
And so he was right in front of Jenna and I. And he turned as Michael, he turns his chair around and straddles it. And it's like an office chair that was very bouncy. It's bouncy. Like it like bobbed up and down and he kept bobbing forward and back, like kind of- Very groiny. Kind of grinding into the chair a little bit like leaning forward and Jenna and I were like so we were like oh my god well you can see my hand is
所以他就在珍娜和我面前。他转过身，作为迈克尔，他转过椅子，跨坐在上面。那是一把非常弹性的办公椅。它很有弹性。它像上下跳动，他不停地前后跳动，有点像——非常猥琐。有点像在椅子上磨蹭，有点像向前倾，珍娜和我当时想，天哪，好吧，你可以看到我的手
up by my mouth through most of that scene and it was because when I started to break I would cover my mouth it was so hard not to just laugh through the whole scene because he was so brilliantly being this cringey boss who's so inappropriate but is trying to do something good for the office, like all of his intentions, you know? That was the scene that I think I broke the most in for this episode. It was that, with him just like grinding into that chair. But you were making it worse because you were right next to me. And if you notice, for the rest of the episode,
在那个场景的大部分时间里都在嘴边，这是因为当我开始笑场时，我会捂住嘴，很难不整场戏都笑出来，因为他如此出色地扮演了这个令人尴尬的老板，他非常不合适，但试图为办公室做点好事，就像他所有的意图一样，你知道吗？我认为我在这一集中笑场最多的就是那个场景。就是那个，他那样磨蹭那把椅子。但你让情况变得更糟，因为你就坐在我旁边。如果你注意的话，在这一集的其余部分，
we are separated. We're separated. Also, I don't know if you noticed, but I try really hard not to look at you. Like, cause I was like, I couldn't look at you, but I could see your shoulders shaking. Yeah. Or I could like sense you shaking.
我们分开了。我们分开了。另外，我不知道你有没有注意到，我非常努力地不看你。因为我当时想，我不能看你，但我能看到你的肩膀在颤抖。是的。或者我能感觉到你在颤抖。
And then I would just start laughing. And I didn't want to laugh. I guess I did. I was like, oh God, I was still like every day, be like, please don't fire me. Please don't fire me. Yes. Please don't fire me. We were trying to me. Yes. Please don't fire me.
然后我就会开始大笑。我不想笑。我想我确实笑了。我当时想，哦天哪，我每天都想，请不要解雇我。请不要解雇我。是的。请不要解雇我。我们试图——是的。请不要解雇我。
We were trying to be professionals. We're trying to be professionals. And Steve is so professional. But I want to challenge you guys if Steve Carell turned to chair around backwards and started kind of like leaning into it. Close to you. It was so close to us.
我们试图成为专业人士。我们试图成为专业人士。史蒂夫非常专业。但我想要挑战你们，如果史蒂夫·卡瑞尔把椅子向后转，开始有点像靠在上面。靠近你。它离我们太近了。
It was very close. I feel like the scene itself doesn't properly communicate how close. It doesn't. Well, I did a little bit of background looking and there is a reflection of us in the television screen when the shots are on Steve. And I think if you look really closely at the reflection,
它非常近。我觉得场景本身并没有充分传达出有多近。确实没有。好吧，我做了一些背景调查，当镜头在史蒂夫身上时，电视屏幕上有我们的倒影。我想如果你仔细看那个倒影，
you can see me break one time. Oh my God. You and I have become like obsessed with our own show. It's so ridiculous. It's a little odd. It's a little odd. Okay, I have a quick story about those note cards we had to tape to our foreheads.
你可以看到我笑场了一次。天哪。你和我已经变得像沉迷于我们自己的剧集一样了。这太荒谬了。这有点奇怪。这有点奇怪。好吧，我有一个关于我们必须贴在额头上的那些笔记卡的简短故事。
Oh yes. Okay, so here's the thing guys. Imagine taping a note card to your forehead because it had the double stick tape so it would stay in place. Imagine putting that on at 7.30 in the morning and not taking it off till like 5 PM.
哦是的。好吧，事情是这样的，伙计们。想象一下把一张笔记卡贴在额头上，因为它有双面胶，所以它会固定在原位。想象一下早上7点半贴上它，直到下午5点才取下来。
Which is what we did. Which is what we did. I mean, we did take it off at lunch for 30 minutes, but then we had to put it back on. At the end of the day of wearing that double stick tape on my forehead, when we took that note card off, it had peeled off all my baby hairs on my forehead. Yes. And I had a strip, like a bare strip on my forehead. And so the next morning when we went into hair and makeup,
这就是我们做的。这就是我们做的。我的意思是，我们在午餐时取下来了30分钟，但之后我们不得不把它贴回去。在额头上戴了一整天双面胶后，当我们取下那张笔记卡时，它把我额头上的所有细小绒毛都撕掉了。是的。我的额头上有一条，像一条光秃秃的条纹。所以第二天早上当我们去化妆时，
the makeup would not adhere to my forehead. It was like you had waxed your forehead in one tiny rectangle spot. Yes, and a few of us had that. A few of us like, I mean, I'm so fair that like my skin like shows everything, but I had kind of like this like this rectangle hickey on my forehead of where that note card had been there all day.
化妆品无法附着在我的额头上。就像你在额头上打了一小块长方形的蜡一样。是的，我们中有几个人有这种情况。我们中有几个人，我的意思是，我皮肤太白了，所以我的皮肤显示出一切，但我额头上有一种像长方形吻痕的东西，那是那张笔记卡整天待过的地方。
Well, I remember us walking around backstage, getting snacks, using the restroom. They didn't want us to take it off. No, because then they'd have to, you know, it was a continuity thing. They didn't want it to be in any way different. Yeah, they took photos of us to make sure it was always in the exact same spot. It wasn't too high or too low. And once they taped it on, they were really like, guys, please don't take your note card off your forehead. So imagine being like, oh, we have a 15 minute break. I'm going to get some pretzels and a cheese stick, but I'm eating the cheese stick and pretzels while wearing, you know, a note card on my head that said Jamaica. That's how we walked around.
好吧，我记得我们在后台走来走去，吃零食，上厕所。他们不想让我们把它取下来。不，因为那样他们就得，你知道，这是一个连贯性问题。他们不想让它有任何不同。是的，他们给我们拍了照片以确保它总是在完全相同的位置。它不会太高或太低。一旦他们把它贴上，他们真的就像，伙计们，请不要把笔记卡从额头上取下来。所以想象一下，哦，我们有15分钟休息时间。我要去拿些椒盐卷饼和奶酪棒，但我一边吃奶酪棒和椒盐卷饼，一边戴着，你知道，头上贴着一张写着“牙买加”的笔记卡。这就是我们走来走去的样子。
Like we went to the bathroom. Yeah. Oh my Lord. A lot of people asked about the note cards. Like was there, did we have any say in what our note card said? No, no, it was all scripted. It wasn't random. A lot of people ask questions about how much improvisation
就像我们去洗手间一样。是的。哦，天哪。很多人问关于笔记卡的事。就像有没有，我们对笔记卡上写什么有发言权吗？不，不，全是剧本写的。它不是随机的。很多人问关于即兴表演有多少
happened in the scenes with the note cards. All that was scripted. All scripted. Dwight saying, oh man, am I a woman? That was scripted. There was even a deleted scene in there where Jim pranks Dwight after Dwight figures out what his race is.
发生在有笔记卡的场景中。所有这些都是剧本写的。全是剧本。德怀特说，哦天哪，我是个女人吗？那是剧本写的。甚至还有一个删除的场景，吉姆在德怀特弄清楚他的种族后捉弄他。
Jim gives him a new card and he's like, here race is, Jim gives him a new card. And he's like, here, here, you should have this new card. And Dwight tapes it to his head. And what Jim's written on it is Dwight. And so I remember filming scenes where he's walking around the room and we're all saying things like, oh, man, you're annoying. You're difficult to be around. Yeah, yeah.
吉姆给了他一张新卡，他说，这里种族是，吉姆给了他一张新卡。他说，这里，这里，你应该有这张新卡。德怀特把它贴在头上。吉姆在上面写的是“德怀特”。所以我记得拍摄场景时，他在房间里走来走去，我们都在说，哦，天哪，你真烦人。你很难相处。是的，是的。
And he's guessing all these different things. And then really it just says Dwight on his forehead. Okay, so I heard there was a deleted scene and guys, I bought the DVDs, okay? I bought the DVDs at Target, but I don't have a DVD player. This is your problem. You're very close to being able to enjoy this DVD.
他在猜所有这些不同的东西。但实际上它只是在他的额头上写着“德怀特”。好吧，所以我听说有一个删除的场景，伙计们，我买了DVD，好吗？我在塔吉特买了DVD，但我没有DVD播放机。这是你的问题。你离享受这张DVD只有一步之遥。
I know. You're one major step away. I'm one major step. I forgot we didn't have a DVD player anymore. So I have them, but I read that there was a deleted scene where Devin, Devin who sat in the background with Creed has a note card on his forehead and you see it, I think he's outside and as Michael walks in,
我知道。我离主要步骤只有一步之遥。我忘了我们不再有DVD播放机了。所以我有了它们，但我读到有一个删除的场景，德文，那个坐在背景里和克里德坐在一起的德文，他的额头上有一张笔记卡，你看到了，我想他在外面，当迈克尔走进来时，
he's outside and his note card says, West Nile. I don't know that. Is that true? I don't know that. Is that true? I don't know. That's so funny. If you get a DVD player, will you come back and tell us? Yes, I've got to get to the bottom of that. I do want to talk about one scene because when I put it out on Twitter that we were
他在外面，他的笔记卡上写着“西尼罗河”。我不知道那个。那是真的吗？我不知道。那是真的吗？我不知道。那太有趣了。如果你买个DVD播放机，你会回来告诉我们吗？是的，我得查个水落石出。我确实想谈谈一个场景，因为当我在推特上发布我们正在
recording this episode, the most frequently asked question was about the scene where Mindy slaps Steve. Oh yeah. People had a lot of questions about that scene. And I remember filming that. And the reason I remember filming it is because Mindy could not stop laughing. Mindy could not stop laughing. She laughed every single take.
录制这一集时，最常被问到的问题是关于明迪扇史蒂夫耳光的场景。哦是的。人们对那个场景有很多问题。我记得拍摄那个场景。我记得拍摄它的原因是因为明迪无法停止大笑。明迪无法停止大笑。她每次拍摄都笑。
Every take and we had, we were all standing there watching. Yes. And she, every time it was time for her to slap Steve, she would laugh. But then right after she slapped Steve, she would laugh. One thing we should say, and a lot of people wondered, was the slap real or fake? Well, I remember we shot that so many times. And the majority of the time it was fake. It was fake. She made no contact with him because people wanted to know, Oh my gosh, did he have a big red mark on his face or anything like that?
每次拍摄我们都站在那里看。是的。而且她，每次轮到她扇史蒂夫耳光时，她都会笑。但就在她扇完史蒂夫耳光后，她又会笑。我们应该说的一件事，很多人想知道，耳光是真的还是假的？好吧，我记得我们拍了很多次。大多数时候它是假的。它是假的。她没有和他有任何接触，因为人们想知道，天哪，他的脸上有没有大红印之类的？
And no, she, and thank goodness it was fake, because she kept breaking every time. It was like unusable. I feel like I do remember Steve, and I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, I do feel like I remember him in one take saying, I think you, you know, just go ahead and hit me once. Yes.
没有，她，谢天谢地它是假的，因为她每次都笑场。这简直无法使用。我觉得我确实记得史蒂夫，我不知道你是否记得这个，珍娜，我确实觉得我记得他在一次拍摄中说，我想你，你知道，直接打我一次就行了。是的。
Go ahead and hit me one time. Right. So I think there was one where she made contact with him. And there was also one time she didn't laugh, and that's the time it's in the episode. That's it. That's it. But I think if you look really closely, you can see.
直接打我一次。对。所以我认为有一次她确实和他有接触。还有一次她没笑，那就是出现在剧集里的那一次。就是这样。就是这样。但我认为如果你仔细看，你可以看到。
I mean, we know Mindy. Yeah. I think I can see her. Her eyes are laughing a little bit. Or she does a thing where she doesn't close her mouth all the way, and that's because she's about to laugh, and she's trying not to. Here's the thing, we got to know each other all so well that I know everyone's tell before they break. It's just so clear when someone's about to laugh. Another thing more than one person asked, I guess there's a controversy.
我的意思是，我们了解明迪。是的。我想我能看到她。她的眼睛在笑。或者她做了一个动作，她没有完全闭上嘴，那是因为她快要笑了，她在努力忍住。事情是这样的，我们彼此了解得太好了，以至于在他们笑场之前我就知道每个人的信号。当有人快要笑出来时，这太明显了。还有一件事不止一个人问，我想有一个争议。
Is Steve saying cookie cookie or googie googie? He's saying googie googie. Googie googie. Yeah. Yes. Well, I'm glad we could solve that controversy. I have some note cards, m'lady. Let's do a note card. OK.
史蒂夫是在说“cookie cookie”还是“googie googie”？他在说“googie googie”。“googie googie”。是的。好吧，我很高兴我们能解决那个争议。我有一些笔记卡，女士。让我们做一张笔记卡。好吧。
All right, this is a very sort of dorky actor moment, so just bear with me. But I thought John, as Jim, did such a fantastic job on the phone with Mr. Decker when he loses his sale to Dwight. Oh, it is one of the hardest things in the world to have a fake one-sided phone conversation. That has hills and valleys of emotion.
好吧，这是一个非常书呆子气的演员时刻，所以请忍受我。但我认为约翰作为吉姆，在电话里和德克尔先生交谈时表现得太棒了，当时他输掉了给德怀特的销售。哦，这是世界上最困难的事情之一，进行一场虚假的单方面电话交谈。它有情感的起伏。
Yes. Where you're reacting like this, he's excited, then he's disappointed, then he like figures out what happened. And there's no one on the other line. No one. There's no one speaking to you. John is just doing that on his own.
是的。你像这样反应，他很兴奋，然后他很失望，然后他弄清楚发生了什么。电话那头没有人。没有人。没有人跟你说话。约翰只是独自一人在做那个。
And I just sat there and I rewatched it. And John, I just want you to know, you crushed that phone call. You are so right. I thought you did such a great job. Yeah. Now I have done films or I have done things where someone is on the other line. For example, in season nine, when Pam breaks down crying at her desk, they figured out a way to wire in John Krasinski live so I could hear him in my ear. So there are times when there's a really emotional scene or a scene that really requires you to speak
我坐在那儿又看了一遍。约翰，我想让你知道，你那通电话打得太棒了。你说得太对了。我觉得你演得真好。是的。我拍过电影，也演过一些戏，对方演员在电话那头。比如在第九季，当帕姆在办公桌前崩溃大哭时，他们想办法把约翰·卡拉辛斯基的现场声音接入我的耳机，这样我就能听到他的声音。所以，有些情感强烈的戏，或者确实需要你和对方演员对话的戏，会有这种情况，
to the other actor, but like 90% of the time you are just pretending someone's there. There's no one there. Yeah, exactly. And so John was just talking to Mr. Decker, who wasn't there, and I just thought he did such a great job. So anyway, I just had to give a little love to JK. Yeah. And after that scene, when Jim finds out that he has lost the sale, that Dwight stole the sale, that is 25% of his income, he goes back into the conference room where Michael is wrapping things up and everyone is bored to tears. And that is when Pam falls asleep on Jim's shoulder. And we filmed that about, oh my goodness,
但90%的时间里，你只是在假装有人在那儿。其实根本没人。是的，没错。所以约翰当时只是在和不在场的德克先生说话，我觉得他演得太好了。总之，我必须得夸夸JK。是的。在那场戏之后，当吉姆发现他丢了那笔生意，发现德怀特抢走了那笔生意，那可是他25%的收入，他回到会议室，迈克尔正在做总结，大家都无聊透顶。就在那时，帕姆靠在吉姆的肩膀上睡着了。我们拍那场戏拍了大概，天哪，
like 15, 16 times that scene, because this was our Jim Pam moment of the episode. This was it. And they really wanted to get these little Jim Pam moments just perfectly. I looked up this scene in the script, and there is a piece of stage direction that BJ Novak wrote that I want to read for you,
拍了15、16次，因为这是这一集中我们的吉姆和帕姆时刻。就是这个。他们真的想把这些吉姆和帕姆的小瞬间拍得完美无缺。我查了剧本里的这场戏，BJ·诺瓦克写了一段舞台指导，我想读给你听，
because I think it is so perfect. He wrote, Jim reacts to Pam falling asleep on him like a butterfly has landed on his shoulder. Isn't that so poetic? That's so poetic. That is so sweet. And so that's what John had in his mind. That was his inspiration for how to react to that. That is so sweet. How special to have a butterfly land on your shoulder and you don't want to move and you want to save it. Yeah. Oh, that is so sweet. Well, I wrote, you know, this is equally as just insightful, you guys. I wrote on my note card, what a great jam moment at the end. And Jenna's skin
因为我觉得它太完美了。他写道：吉姆对帕姆靠在他身上睡着的反应，就像一只蝴蝶落在了他的肩膀上。这不是很诗意吗？太诗意了。太甜了。所以这就是约翰当时的想法。这就是他如何反应的灵感来源。太甜了。蝴蝶落在肩膀上，你不想动，想保护它，这多特别啊。是的。哦，太甜了。好吧，我写了，你知道，这同样很有见地，伙计们。我在我的笔记卡上写道，结尾的吉姆时刻太棒了。而且珍娜的皮肤
looks flawless. Well, thank you, Angela, because I did notice in an earlier shot, there is a shot of my skin that looks just terrible. Well, we didn't have like any makeup on really, like at all, like barely any makeup. Powder blush and a little mascara. Right, and I had one strip of powder that wouldn't stick to my forehead anymore.
看起来完美无瑕。好吧，谢谢你，安吉拉，因为我确实注意到在早些时候的一个镜头里，我的皮肤看起来糟透了。好吧，我们当时几乎没怎么化妆，真的，几乎没化什么妆。只有粉底腮红和一点睫毛膏。没错，我额头上还有一块粉底怎么也贴不住了。
So I don't know, Jenna, I thought your skin looked flawless. Well, you know what, to wrap it up, why don't we do one last fan question. Okay. Alexia asked if there were any scenes that were taken out that we wish had made it in. And I picked this fan question because my answer is yes. Okay, which one? I was in it. Well, what is it? explains what a hero is and it's an acronym. And then Dwight explains what he thinks a hero is. Well, after all that happened, there was a scene where Michael stands up and creates his own acronym
所以我不知道，珍娜，我觉得你的皮肤看起来完美无瑕。好吧，你知道吗，为了结束这一集，我们来回答最后一个粉丝问题吧。好的。亚历克西娅问有没有什么被删减掉的戏是我们希望保留下来的。我选了这个粉丝问题，因为我的回答是肯定的。好的，是哪一段？我参与了那场戏。好吧，是什么？解释什么是英雄，这是一个首字母缩略词。然后德怀特解释了他认为什么是英雄。好吧，在那之后，有一场戏是迈克尔站起来，创造了他自己的首字母缩略词
for sensitivity. And his words are inclusion, new attitude, colorblind, expectations, sharing, and tolerance. And while he's saying these words, Dwight is writing them on a whiteboard. And I look at the whiteboard and I say, Michael, that spells incest. And then Steve tap dances and says,
来代表“敏感”。他的词是包容（Inclusion）、新态度（New attitude）、色盲（Colorblind）、期望（Expectations）、分享（Sharing）和宽容（Tolerance）。当他说这些词的时候，德怀特正在白板上写下来。我看着白板说：迈克尔，这拼出来是“乱伦”（Incest）。然后史蒂夫跳起踢踏舞说：
but it still works because incest is bad and discrimination is bad. But also incest is something that happens in your family and the world is our family. Like it just this crazy ramble. Just back away from it. Yeah, but he won't let it go. And then Pam has a talking head that says,
但这仍然行得通，因为乱伦是不好的，歧视也是不好的。但乱伦也是发生在家庭里的事，而世界就是我们的家庭。就像这种疯狂的胡言乱语。赶紧打住吧。是的，但他就是不肯罢休。然后帕姆有一个独白说：
if he just rearranged the words, he could have spelled insect. And I just remember shooting that scene and every time I had to raise my hand and very matter-of-factly point out that it spells incest, then there was just this silence in the room as everyone took it in. And I was sad that went on the cutting room floor. That's very funny. So thank you, Alexia, for your question. All right, everybody.
如果他重新排列一下这些词，他本可以拼出“昆虫”（Insect）。我记得拍那场戏的时候，每次我不得不举起手，一本正经地指出它拼出来是“乱伦”时，房间里就会陷入一片沉默，每个人都在消化这个事实。我很遗憾那段戏被剪掉了。那太搞笑了。所以，谢谢亚历克西娅的问题。好了，各位。
That was Diversity Day. And next week, we're going to be talking about health care. Angela, what do you think about when you think about health care? Hot dog fingers. Hot dog fingers. We're going to talk about hot dog fingers with our first special guest, Rainn Wilson. Yes, that tall drink of water is calling in and we are going to talk about the episode with him so be sure and tune in.
以上就是“多元化日”。下周，我们将讨论“医疗保健”。安吉拉，当你想到医疗保健时，你会想到什么？热狗手指。热狗手指。我们将和我们的第一位特邀嘉宾雷恩·威尔逊讨论热狗手指。是的，那个高个子帅哥会打来电话，我们将和他讨论那一集，所以一定要收听。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。